Thompson is with us in Denver Colorado
hey Thompson how are you I'm great Dave
them looking to do Financial Peace
University for the second time I just
the question is how to stay on track
what kept you from staying on track
before well the local church I went to
did you know they teamed us up with two
people and you know we did the nine week
course and like I said it I didn't do it
so I'm looking for motivation this time
you with a little you sat through the
class for nine weeks and you didn't do
it well no I got the basics but um but
you didn't do a budget and didn't stick
with it right what don't know the answer
that's why I'm calling you I'm just
looking so you do absolutely or do you
stick for that person that or do you
just keep on rolling and read the books
I you know I understand the principles
mm-hmm well I mean I don't think
somebody else can do it for you I think
you've got to want to do it I can lead
you to water but I can't make you drink
the same would be true with the
coordinator in your class I mean they're
gonna play the DVD and show you about
you know the budgeting lesson and and
coach you if you've got any questions
but I mean you're an adult you've got to
go home and do the budget and then oh by
the way you got to live on it so what
makes you want to do that is usually one
of two or three things one would be that
you you can see that if I pay a price
now if I'll discipline myself now I I
can win later if I live like no one else
later I can live and give like no one
else I want a better life and you paint
out real - real clearly define what
better life means I want to travel I
want to buy this I want to give money to
this cause I want to have an ambition
and the desire to do X Y or Z and you
write down X Y or Z and that makes it
worth going through the crap you go
through to get your life straightened
out to be able to do those things so
that's that's kind of a positive side of
motivation then the negative side of
motivation would be you just get really
disgusted in the sick and tired of being
a freaking broke all the time you decide
to do something about it yeah that's
that's format so that's why I'm calling
yeah the great the great you know the
great motivator Les Brown says that if
people change their lives when they
finally say I've had it I'm sick and
tired of this and you you know you have
to decide that I can't decide that for
you right okay
so that that's how you get started now
you know you get around a group of
people in these group discussions and
all while you're going through the nine
week class and that gives you some
encouragement you know if you're
discouraged people can talk you know you
can have a place to vent that or if
you're you know if you feel like you're
just falling off the wagon so to speak
somebody can hold you the accountability
and the encouragement during that nine
weeks gives you a track to run on but
you know you got to decide I had to roll
out of bed you know at 5:05 this morning
so I could do my run this morning before
I come down here and work all day before
I apply it's a lot of Pittsburgh tonight
I don't have to do that nobody's gonna
make me get up and run in the morning
but I like food and so I have to do that
I like food a little too much and then
does it seemed I don't seem to be able
to outrun it so I've been trying for
years but anyway that you know the
personal struggle but that that's the
that's the thing you got to do I mean
you got to look at the thing and go what
have I got to change in my life and
that's when people change their lives
hey thanks for the call you'll have a
good friend who's considerably
overweight and he's a good enough friend
that I talked to him about that I said
dude you're gonna freaking die I mean
you're not just fat you're obese I mean
you're gonna die this is gonna kill you
he's a good enough friend that you know
I can do that with him and you know one
one or two of his other friends did that
and one of his kids talked to him and
then he went the doctor the other day
the doctor said you have the heart of an
80 year old you're gonna die if you
don't lose this weight and we're
probably gonna have to do our open heart
surgery you know he told me he said I
everybody's told me for years then they
do something bout this he said you told
me you said right there in that chair
and you told me and he said but when the
doctor looks at you and says you're
gonna die he said you
those donuts just don't look appealing
anymore that chocolate-chip cookie it is
not it does not have the draw that it
used to have and he said you know he's
dropped like he dropped like ten pounds
in one week it's amazing absolutely
amazing and but you know it's all of a
sudden you know you're gonna die
that's a little different than I'd like
to be able to fit in my pants a little
better you know a little different level
of motivation there and so here's the
thing you got to get it in your head
that you're gonna work your whole life
and end up broke you're gonna die
financially you're gonna work your whole
life in the richest country of the world
has ever known
where opportunity was at your fingertips
that every time you turn the corner it
was staring you in the face great ideas
are a dime a dozen ways to implement
them and bring them to market or
everywhere now and you're gonna work
your whole life and I broke if you don't
do something about this I think it's
time it's time you do something about it
don't wait till the doctor comes and
goes you're gonna die to take action
make a decision you get to make a
decision but you know what you've got to
make the decision I can't make it for
you
I will I will never lose weight because
my wife wants me lose weight it will
never happen you will never complete
that college degree because your mom I
wanted you to you will do it because you
set a goal that you wanted to accomplish
for you for some reason don't retire for
over don't let millions of dollars flow
through your hands in your working
lifetime and have nothing to show for it
get up off your butt and do something
about it
that's to everyone not just our last
caller this is the Dave Ramsey show
you